all right i want to start today with
sort of like a funny little story that's
actually not really that funny and um it
says a lot about senate uh republican
senate minority leader mitch mcconnell
so yesterday on the show i kind of gave
you guys my perspective on this joe
biden has said he will choose a black
woman to the supreme court
and um the question was posed to mitch
mcconnell in the context of
you know sort of an expectation that
there may be funny business with mitch
mcconnell when it comes to joe biden's
eventual supreme court pick and so on
and so forth and it doesn't even matter
mitch mcconnell was asked how many black
women work for him
and um first mitch mcconnell twice
appears not to hear or understand the
question until the reporter pulls his
mask down and then later he says he
doesn't actually know because he doesn't
have a quota for black women which was a
very cynical attempt to turn the
question back as a racist question and
it completely backfires so let's look at
the first clip here is mitch mcconnell
twice asked about how many black women
are on his staff and he can't hear it
doesn't understand it how many black
women do you have on staff and how are
they informing your decision to move
forward with the scoliosis nomination
and same question to the other senators
how many what how many black women do
you have on your staff and are they
informing your decision on how to move
forward with this golden nomination
and same question to the other senators
okay so mitch mcconnell asks that the
reporters uh uh mask be pulled down
that's pablo manriquez
um from latino rebels so when when pablo
asked the question for the third time
mitch mcconnell responds to try to make
the question seem racist how many black
women do you have on staff and how are
they informing your decision yeah
yeah actually i haven't checked we don't
have a racial quota in my office but
i've had a number of african-american
employees both male and female over the
years in all kinds of different
positions including speech writer
so um
he doesn't know and he wants to make it
seem like asking that is racist because
i have no quota and if you're asking me
how many black women i have on staff you
know sort of like a binder's full of
women mitt romney type incident you're
you're that's a it's an inappropriate
question
it's a bizarre answer because senate
senate staffs are not so big
that you would have no idea it's like
are are there do you have any black
women that that work for you and we can
argue it doesn't matter we can argue
it's an appropriate question like i'm
not saying those things but that's an
argument we can have
but is this at all believable like it's
not it's not racist to just know the
answer
um you know if someone came to me and
said sir
uh when you worked at circuit city
how many black women worked with you
this was 20 years ago there were about
80 people that i worked with at circuit
city i would be able to tell you it was
three or four
that was a long time ago and i'm saying
three or four because i don't remember
whether
all four worked there with me at the
same time or whatever the case may be
but there were there were three or four
black women that worked with me at
circuit city 20 years ago if you and
it's not just about
black women if you said how many asian
men worked with me as part of my
internship remember when i got licensed
for life insurance and i sold life
insurance for a summer and i hated it
and i knew financial working and
financial planning is not for me you say
how many asian men were part of the
intern cadre with you i can tell you
with certainty there were none
there were none there was no quota
it's not racist to remember it it just
kind of like is what it is and so when
mitch mcconnell says it's a total
backfire if if the question was how many
black women were at your last political
rally where there were 500 people
saying i don't know i didn't it's it's
completely reasonable and plausible
uh if you say you know if you say david
how many native americans were with you
in fifth grade in your fifth grade class
there were none i know that there were
no native americans in my fifth grade
class there were
curricula about native americans and it
was a topic that there were no native
americans in the class it was a topic of
discussion it's not racist to remember
that it's just very hard when asked
these questions you know and and part of
the funny thing is
the right
uh loves to say
and they are correct
that as humans
and and many on the left say this too
but the right also says they say as
humans
you can't not notice certain attributes
when you meet someone without prejudice
you're immediately judging
am i talking to an old person or a young
person right you're not going to have a
conversation with someone and then they
go was that a kid or was that an adult i
i don't know i don't see age it's like
no of course you do
you would know whether that was someone
between 50 and 70 or a little kid you
would know that you're immediately
evaluating gender and sometimes you
could be wrong sure but you're you're
immediately evaluating it
you're generally speaking evaluating
race it doesn't mean you can always tell
is it was that person
indian american or not it doesn't mean
you're always doing it accurately but
you're instantly making these
evaluations about people so the right
loves to say that
and they're correct that these things
happen it doesn't make you racist to
notice those things but then mitch
mcconnell has asked like from your
senate staff how many black women do you
have you go i don't know no i mean we
don't have any quotas it implies the
question is racist the last part of this
is
if he really doesn't know
everybody who works for him that's
another level of sort of like
cringe-worthy narcissism which is maybe
a topic for another day but like if it's
true that he doesn't know
it's very very strange and it could be
one of those like we don't ever look at
the senator sort of things
i actually don't think that that's what
it is i think
i think the answer is zero
and mitch mcconnell was just attempting
to make the questions seem racist
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time all you have to do is
take a short quiz on their website a
licensed doctor approves your
prescription the medication comes
straight to your home within days in a
discreet package no driving around to
the doctor's office or the pharmacy no
waiting around no awkward conversations
with your doctor all of blue chews
tablets are made in the usa the entire
process is just a few clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping